[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا مساء الخير انا ميسون
واهد واقدم لكم اخبار الساعه كالعاده نبدا
بابرز العناوين
في السودان انفجارات واشتباكات وعنف
الخرطوم ودارفور المنكوبه تحصد مزيدا من
الارواح
بلس تخفض انتاجها لعام 2020 بواقع مليون
و400 الف برميل يوميا وزير الطاقه
السعوديه يعتبره قرارا غير مسبوق
من الهجمات الى عمليات الاسر بالقرود
الروسيه في مرمى الاستهدافات الاوكرانيه
والمناطق الحدوديه تتحول لمدن اشباح
في خطوه نحو انهاء الازمه السوريه هيئه
التفاوض المعارضه تعلن ان الظرف مناسب
لاستئناف المفاوضات المباشره
[موسيقى]
نبدا اخبار الساعه من السودان وكان انتهاء
الهدنه كان جرس العوده الى المسلسل الدامي
فقد ازدادت حده المعارك في اليومين
الماضيين الاشتباكات دخلت اسبوعها الثامن
ليعلو صوت المدافع والغارات الجويه في
سماء العاصمه الخرطوم شنتها قوات الجيش
بينما ردت عليها قوات الدعم السريع
بالمضادات الارضيه كما اعلن الدعم السريع
اسقاط طائره تابعه للجيش من طراز ميج وذلك
اثر الغارات التي شنها الجيش على مواقع
تابعه لقوات الدعم في منطقه بحري ومن
الخرطوم الى دارفور حيث تجددت الاشتباكات
على وجه التحديد في مدينه كتم ليعلن حاكم
دارفور ميني اركوناوي الاقليم منطقه
منكوبه بعدما شهدتهم النهب وقتل وانتهاكات
فظيعه
[موسيقى]
قال قائد الدعم الساريه السودانيه محمد
حمدان دقلو انه اكد في اتصال مع وزير
الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان
دعمه لمنبر جده والتزامه باعلان حمايه
المدنيين وتسهيل ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه واضاف دجله في بيان ان هناقش مع
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الاوضاع في
السودان وجهود الوساطه فضلا عن تبادل
وجهات النظر حول اخر التطورات في البلاد
واضاف حملتي تاكيده على اهميه التنسيق
وتكثيف الجهود المشتركه من اجل تحقيق
الاستقرار في السودان وفق البيان
من الخرطوم ينضم الى الصحفيه عمار ابو
شيبه عمار اهلا بك معنا الانباء تتحدث عن
اشتباكات عنيفه اليوم في الخرطوم اين
تركزت وكيف يمكن ان تصف لنا الوضع اليوم
في الخرطوم
اهلا بك يا ميسون واهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام
نعم ميسون هذه الاشتباكات دارت في عده
مناطق هنا في شرق العاصمه الخرطوم وفي
منطقه شرق النيل بالتحديد في منطقه الجريف
شرق حيث دارت فيها عده اشتباكات وتم فيها
قصفا جويا على هذه المنطقه في منطقه جنوب
العاصمه الخرطوم عدد من المناطق التي كانت
تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم السريع تم فيها
ايضا قصفا جويا هنالك مصادر طبيه غير
محليه تم التحدث معها تحدثنا اليها اشارت
الى سقوط ضحايا من المدنيين في هذه
المنطقه خاصه المناطق احياء العشرة ومايو
ايضا في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم عده اشتباكات
استمعنا الى دوري المدافع التي تحدث الان
في منطقه بوري الشرق العاصمه الخرطوم
المتاخمه للقياده العامه هذه الاشتباكات
البريه في منطقه بوري ما بين الجيش والدعم
السريع تدور منذ اكثر من ساعه ونصف ما بين
القوتين هذه الاشتباكات نستمع فيها الى
دوري المدافع هنالك رضوى رد من الطرف
الاخر في هذه المنطقه ايضا تحدثنا الى عدد
من المصادر في منطقه غرب العاصمه الخرطوم
دارت فيها عدد من الاشتباكات خاصه في شارع
الغابه صباح اليوم هذه الاشتباكات امتدت
ميسون حتى وصلت الى مدينه شمال بحري هذه
المدينه التي تدور في راحها عدد كبير من
الاشتباكات منذ اكثر من شهر ودخلنا الى
اليوم الخمسين هنالك طائره تم اسقاطها من
قبل قوات الدعم السريع بحسب ما تحدثت في
بيان لها صباح اليوم الجيش لم يعلق على
حادثه سقوط الطائره ولكن شهود عيان راوا
الطائره تحترقها من ثم تسقط في مدينه ام
درمان مدينه ام درمان ايضا لم تكن بعيدا
عن هذه الاشتباكات دارت فيها اشتباكات عده
خاصه فيهم درمان القديمه في محيط الاذاعه
والتلفزيون كان هنالك تدوين مدفعيا ايضا
من سلاح المهندسين وايضا في منطقه
عده اشتباكات ما يعني اتساع رقعه
الاشتباكات في العاصمه الخرطوم والعوده
الى المربع الاول بشكل عنيف هذه
الاشتباكات ايضا كانت في مدينه او ولايات
دارفور في منطقه كتم بشمال ادار فور هذا
يدل بشكل واضح ميسون اننا عدنا الى المربع
الاول مربع الاشتباكات العنيفه والقصف
العنيف ما بين الجانبين الذي يؤدي الى
كثير من الكوارث ابرزها عدد من الضحايا
نعم
وتجددت معه الدعوات الاقليميه والدوليه
للتوصل الى هدنه ومن ثم الى وقف اطلاق نار
تامه فقد اكدت السعوديه والولايات المتحده
في بيان مشترك على الالتزام بمصلحه الشعب
السوداني كما دعت طرفين نزاع لهدنه جديده
خاصه ان وفدي الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع ما زالات في مدينه جده حتى مع
تعليق المفاوضات وانتهاء مده الهدنه
السابقه والتي استمرت خمسه ايام الرياض
واشنطن شددتا على طرفين نزاع الالتزام
باعلان جده الخاص بحمايه المدنيين في
السودان وتسهيل المساعدات الانسانيه كما
لفت البيان الى الانتباه لضروره الالتزام
باي هدنه جديده بهدف التوصل الى وقف دائم
لاعمل العنف
[موسيقى]
السؤال الان مشاهدينا لماذا لا تستمر
الهدنه في السودان محللون يجيبون بان
الطرفين نزاعي وافقان على اي هدنه بهدف
استغلال الوقت لاعداد ترتيب الصفوف
والتقاط الانفاس واعاده التموضع كما
انعدام اليات الرقبه الاقليميه والدوليه
على عمليه تنفيذ الهدنه يسمح للطرفين
باتهام الاخر بخرقها لكن الاهم انه من
الصعب اقناع اي من الجنرلين المتحاربين
برهان وحمتي بالتفاهم وتوصل لوقف النهائي
لاطلاق النار بينما كل طرف منهما يدعي
امتلاك الشرعيه ويرمي الطرف الاخر بتهم
مختلفه ويسعى كل منهما لان تكون له اليد
العليا في المفاوضات
[موسيقى]
والان الى موضوع
اجتماع ماراثوني لتحالفك بلس وصفه ووزير
الطاقه السعوديه بغير المسبوق من حيث
النوعيه ومدى التعاون للتواصل اليه تضمن
خصنا للانتاج في عام 24 بواقع مليون و400
الف برميل يوميا من مستويات اكتوبر 20 22
متابع
اختتم تحالف اوبك بلاستيج اجتماعات استمرت
ليومين بعد التوصل لاتفاق جديد تضمن مستوى
مستهدفا جديدا للانتاج عند اربعين مليون
و460 الف برميل يوميا بدايه من عشرين
اربعه وعشرين ما يعني تخفيض الانتاج في 20
24 بواقع مليون و400 الف برميل يوميا من
مستويات اكتوبر 20 22
بعد ذلك خرجت السعوديه باعلان منفصل حيث
اعلنت عن تمديد الخفض الطوعي الذي اعلنته
سابقا بمقدار 500 الف برميل يوميا حتى
نهايه 20 24 كما اعلنت عن تخفيض تطوعيا
اضافي لشهر واحد قابلا للتمديد اعتبارا من
اول يوليو بمقدار مليون برميل يوميا ليصبح
انتاج السعوديه تسعه ملايين برميل يوميا
ويكون مجموع خفض المملكه التطوعي مليونا
ونصف المليون برميل يوميا هذا قرار يساعد
على يعني تعزيز فرص استقرار الاسواق ومنعه
من التذبذب الحاد والتذبذب الحاد ياخذ من
الناحيتين نشف فقط الى الاسفل ولكن ايضا
الى الاعلى نعتقد ان هذه الاجراءات هي
الاجراءات التي يجب ان نتصرف اننا ناخذها
كمنتجين مسؤولين عن
في الاعتبار عند تحديد مستويات الانتاج في
20 25 محمد زهير العربيه
الخبير الاقتصادي دكتور يوسف الشمري دكتور
يوسف مساء الخير اهلا بك معنا الى اي حد
هذا القرار اليوم سيساهم باستقرار سوق
النفط بمنع التذبذب وايضا هل هو كافن
لاستعاده التوازن في الاسواق
اهلا وسهلا ميسون وسعيد في الحديث هذا
المسامع العربيه في الحقيقه بغض النظر انه
القرار اليوم اعتقد انه المجموعه حققت
نجاحات كبيره النجاح الاول انه نحن عندنا
اتفاق ساري لمده عام كامل في العام فهذا
جدا مهم انه يعطي الاسواق حاله يرفع حاله
عدم اليقين على اليقين حاله اليقين على
العام المقبل هذا الانجاز الاول طبعا
مشاركه روسيا على العضو اهم في تحالف من
الخارج المنظمه عن الجهاز الاخر انه يعني
استطعنا تعديل خطوط الاساس اللي كانت
معلومات غير محدثه من العديد من الدول في
افريقيا ودول اخرى
وايضا تمكنا من رفع مستويات بعض الدول مثل
الامارات العربيه المتحده في بحيث انه
تعطى الدول الحصص اللي تتناسب مع قدراتها
الانتاجيه فهذه خلينا نقول التخفيضات كانت
موجوده ولم تكن تحتسبها الاسواق حاليا هي
موجوده رسميا ضمن قرارات اوبك
الانجاز الاخر انه حتى التخفيضات الطبيعيه
اللي اتخذتها تسع دول في في نفذت في مايو
في الحقيقه سيتم تمديدها بالكامل للعام
المقبل فهذا اندل يعطي للاسواق نوع من
الدفع القويه في العام المقبل 2020
وهذا ما يهم الناس صحيح
خلينا نقول انه بشكل طبيعي هي تعطي دفعه
واستقراريه للعام 2020 نحن الان الحمد لله
يعني خلال انجازه العام 2023
والاستقرار وايضا ومنع المضاربات في السوق
واحنا الان ننظر العام مقبل من التحالف
وتماسك هذا التحالف وهذا يمنع اي نوع من
المضاربات هناك امر اخر
ساعتخذت قرار بتحمل تخفيض اضافي بمليون
برميل يوميا لشهر
لماذا تحملت هذا العبء لوحدها ولم تتقاسمه
مع الدول الاخرى
طبعا المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي استحالف
بلس فدوه خلينا نقول من نوعا ما
وهي دائما تحافظ يعني لما انت تكون قائد
المجموعه لازم يكون لك دور في المحافظه
على تماسك المجموعه فهذا دور العامل لا
يستغرق قامت فيها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في 20 21 قامت فيها ايضا في 2020
في دائما يعني هذه التخفيضات الطوعيه اللي
تتخذها المملكه اولا انها تدعم الاسواق
وتستقراريه وايضا تحافظ على تماسك الاعضاء
وايضا في الاخير زي ما وصفها سمو وزير
الطاقه اللي هي كيك فالاضافه الثلج على
الكعبه التزام اليوم من قبل روسيا
بالالتزام بكافه تعهداتها اهميه هذا الامر
وخاصه من دوله كاروسيا بثقلها الاقتصادي
وخاصه في هذا المجال
روسيا في في حد نظري ميسون اتكلم كمحلل
يعني مال مالها خيال لانه احنا لو نلاحظ
في الاتفاق يعني تم تخفيض حصتها من عشره
او 470 الف الى حوالي الان عندي 980 الف
برميل فهذا طبعا العقوبات اللي فوضتها
عليها الدول الغربيه نوعا ما قللت من
قدراتها الانتاجيه فاوسيا مستفيده من
هكذا قرار لكن خلينا نقول طبعا الان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه حصتها اكبر من
روسيا لكن روسيا طبعا لما يكون هنالك في
تخفيضات من هذا النوع تاخذ
الولايات المتحده ايضا على هذا التخفيض مع
العلم انه التخفيض الذي حصل سابقا وكانت
ممتعده منه الولايات المتحده
اظهر بانه دول اوبك بلاس كانت ادق
بتقييمها لهذا الوضع وبالتالي ايضا كان
السوق مستقرا ولم ترتفع الاسعار
والله ميسون في الولايات المتحده
كانت تفاعلات كانت دائما تاخذ منحه تفاعل
سياسي وليس تفاعل فني من البيت الابيض الى
الكونجرس الى او موجهات المتعدده لكن
خلينا القراءات هذه قرارات جدا فنيه
واثبتت عبر السنوات الماضيه انه انها
قرارات فعلا لا تاخذ بغض النظر اي
احتسابات سياسيه او تحكم بالاسعار او
استهداف اسعار معينه وبالاخير تتمكننا من
استقرايه بينما لو نلاحظ الولايات المتحده
مثلا
كان هنالك في ضخ هائل السيوله في هنالك في
حفاظه على اسعار فائده عند مستوى الصفر
فماذا ادى الان عندنا ازمه تضخم كبيره في
الولايات المتحده فانا اعتقد انه القرار
اللي بتاخذ اليوم قرار جدا فني ولا له اي
ابعاد سياسيه والمفروض انه بالعكس اعتقد
القطاع النفط في صناعه النفط الولايات
المتحده تستفيد من هذا القرار لانه
الاستقرار الاسواق في الاخير يدعم صناعه
الامريكيه يدعم ايضا الاقتصاد عموما
الاقتصادات العالميه فا لمفروض انه يصب في
مصلحه المستهلكين والمنتجين دائما نسعد
بوجودك معنا دكتور يوسف الشمري الخبير
الاقتصادي كنت معي من فيينا شكرا على كل
هذه التوضيحات
[موسيقى]
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعد قليل الامير
هاري امام المحكمه لتقديم افادته بقضيه
العصر
[موسيقى]
الى الشان الاوكراني الروسي الان فيلق
روسيا الحره
كان العامل الاساسي في نقل الصراع الى
الداخل الروسي اخر تحركاته كانت اسرى
جنديين روسيين في بلجرود ليعرض الفيلق
صفقه تبادل على حاكم المنطقه قائلا انه
سيسلم الاسيرين الى
قريه نوفيا تبونزنكا وهو ما وافق عليه
حاكم بالبرود مبدئيا والاستعداد الكامل
للقاء الفيلق مقابل انقاذ الاسيرين
حديث الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا تحول
مؤخرا مشاهدينا الى داخل الروسي بعدما
اشتدت الهجمات على المنطقه الحدوديه في
بيلجرود فبعد هجمات وتوغل للقوات
الاوكرانيه في العمق الروسي بحسب موسكو
استمر القصف على المنطقه خلال الليل وحتى
صباح اليوم حاكم بالقرود صرح ان الحرائق
اندلعت في بلده
اسراء قصف القوات الاوكرانيه لوسط البلده
ضربات ادت الى وقوع خسائر في صفوف
المدنيين بحسب حاكم المنطقه مؤكدا تضرر
البنيه التحتيه والسكنيه في ثلاث في ثلاث
مناطق حدوديه اخرى
[موسيقى]
بعد ان تحولت بالقروده الى منطقه ساخنه
دخل الرعب الى الحياه اليوميه لسكان
المنطقه لتتحول المدينه الى مدينه اشباح
صحيفه نيورتانز الامريكيه قالت ان بالجروب
تشهد عمليات اجلاء للسكان خاصه مع تحول
التشيبي كينو الى خط مواجهه جديد حاكم
الاقليم افاد باجلاء اكثر من 2500 شخص من
السكان ونقلهم الى ملاجئ مؤقته بعيدا عن
المنطقه الحدوديه بالاضافه الى الاف
الفرين حسب شهادات ادلبها سكان المنطقه
[موسيقى]
احس القرى وخصوصا منطقه شبكيني التي تعرضت
للقصف على الاستماع لموقف السلطات
والمغادره مؤقتا من منازلهم من اجل الحفاظ
على اهم شيء وهو حياتهم وحياه المقربين
منهم
من موسكو ينضم الى المحلل السياسي اندريه
اهلا بكم معنا هل يمكن القول الان ان هذه
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا او ما تسميها
روسيا العمليه العسكريه تحولت الان من
اوكرانيا الى الداخل الروسي
هذا صحيح جزئيا بسبب نحن نرى ان توجد هناك
تدخلات للقوات الاوكرانيه الى الاراده
الروسيه يتم استهداف الاماكن المدنيه ولكن
ان اعتقد ان يجب ان ننظر الى اسباب ذلك
اسباب الحقيقيه
فوضح تماما ان حاليا سلطات الاوكرانيه
والجيش الاوكراني يحاول ان يجبر روسيا
لتنقل مزيد من القوات وسحب هذه القوات من
دون باس
منرسون
وتنقل هذه القوات الى بلجره وليس فقط
بوجره بل كذلك بشكل عام الى محافظات التي
تجد على حدود مع اوكرانيا كذلك برانز
وكورسك
بان روسيا بانه اوكرانيا تغير تكتيكاتها
تريد ان تخفف العبء عن دومباس حتى تتمكن
من هجوم هناك وت
ركز الان على بيل قرود ولكن السؤال روسيا
كيف ستتعامل مع هذا او هذه العمليات على
الداخل الروسيه وعلى بالقرود التي تحولت
الى مدينه اشباح
نحن حاليا نعرف بان القاص ياتي من الطرف
الاوكراني من الاراضي الاوكرانيه فنقول
بان طبعا هناك حاجه لتقويه المجموعه
المسلحه الروسيه في تلك المنطقه ولكن ليس
عن طريق سحب
الكتائب من دونباس وناقل الى هذه المنطقه
وهلا على ما يبدو عن طريق نقل الوحدات من
المناطق الشرقيه الروسيه لتقويه هذه
المنطقه الهجمات الاوكرانيه يلفت النظر عن
نحن نرى توغلات للمجموعات الصغيره نسبيا
الاوكرانيه الى اراد الروسيه فلذلك طبعا
روسيا ستتعامل مع هذه التدخلات ولكن من
جديد او ان نقول بان الهدف الرئيسي هو هو
لايداعاف المجموعه الروسيه متواجده في
المنطقه الدنباص لكي تجبر روسيا لتنقل جزء
من هذه المجموعه الى محافظه
يعتبر بانه القوات الروسيه هي غير قادره
حقيقه على صد هذا الاوكرانيا وبالتالي
بالجروب تتعرض الى كل هذا القصف وايضا
تتعرض الى هذا الاجلاء ويتركها الناس حتى
يعني قائد فاجنر بريكوجين قال بانه لن
يترك الامر هكذا في بيل قرود ومن الممكن
ان يتدخل بحال بقاء هذه الفوضى يعني هو
قائد روسي بالنهايه ويقول بان هناك حاله
فوضى داخل القوات الروسيه
هذا ما يقوله
دائما ينتقد القوات الروسيه ولكن حقيقه
الامر هو اننا نحن قد شاهدنا عده تدخلات
للقوات الاوكرانيه الى الاراده الروسيه
بالمجموعات صغيره كما قلت
سابقا وكل هذه المحاولات قد افشلت من قبل
القوات الروسيه انا لا اريد
هناك مشاكل في المحافظ في المناطق
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا هناك حاجه لحل هذه
المشاكل لتقويه المجموعه الروسيه
المتواجده هناك ولكن طبعا الاوضاع ليست
الفوضويه في تلك المنطقه وفي نهايه المطاف
الروسيه تستطيع ان تطرد هذه المجموعات
الاوكرانيه من الاراده الروسيه شكرا لك
المحلل
ليبيا ساحه صراع بين واشنطن وموسكو وذكر
تقرير ان سفير روسيا الجديد في ليبيا
يستعد لتولي منصبه في وقت تفكر فيه امريكا
باعاده فتح سفارتها هناك ويبقى النفط
الليبي مصدر الجذب الاساسي للقوى العالميه
وفق
ليبيا ساحه صراع على النفوذ بين واشنطن
وموسكو فبينما تفكر امريكا في اعاده فتح
سفاراتها في ليبيا يستعد سفير روسيا
الجديد بالفعل لتولي منصبه الجديد في
طرابلس النفط مصدر الجذب الاساسي للقوى
العالميه حسب بلومبرج فمجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه تمتلك بالفعل امكانيه الوصول الى
منشات النفط الرئيسيه في ليبيا كما ان
قرار موسكو باعاده ترسيخ وجودها
الدبلوماسي في طرابلس غربي البلاد اوضح
مؤشر حتى الان على ان بوتين يتطلع الى
تحقيق تقدم يتجاوز دعمه التقليدي للجيش
الليبي
التحركات الروسيه في ليبيا غدت مصدر قلق
كبير لامريكا التي ارسلت عددا من كبار
المسؤولين بينهم رئيس وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه
لمواجهه الدوري الروسي الذي احرزه بوتين
في احد
الذي تتودد اليه الحكومات الاوروبيه كبديل
محتمل للطاقه الروسيه يتصدر جدول الاعمال
الامريكي محاوله للاطاحه بما يقدر بنحو
الفين من قوات فيجنر الذين دعموا حمله
حفتر 2019 2020
للاستيلاء على طرابلس وساعدوا منذ ذلك
الحين في تعزيز قبضته على امدادات النفط
في بلد يضم اربعين في المئه من احتياطيات
افريقيا
لكن الولايات المتحده في وضع غير مواطن في
ليبيا حيث لا توجد لديها قوات ولا وجود
دبلوماسيا حتى الان
اما الكرملين فيدرك ان امريكا تريد اضعاف
نفوذ روسيا في ليبيا كما يبدو ان بوتين قد
استقر على سياسه دعم الوضع الراهن وهو وضع
يحتمل ان يترك صدرات النفط الليبيه
رهينه لروسيا التي تشعر بضغوط العقوبات
على مبيعاتها من النفط الخام
[موسيقى]
الان الى المشهد السوري والذي متى يتجه
الى ضوء لنهايه النفق بعد جنود القضيه
سياسيا
فالمعارضه السوريه ادت ليونه تجاه الحكومه
السوريه مصرحه ان الظرف بات مناسبا
لاستئناف المفاوضات المباشره التصريح جاء
عقب اجتماع هيئه التفاوض السوريه التابعه
للمعارضه في جناب والتي كشف عن مخرجات
اجتماعها في اطار توحيد موقف المعارضه
المتوزعه على منصات المعارضه مؤيده لمبدا
خطوه مقابل خطوه بعد مناقشه بيان عمان
واعلان جده والمبادره العربيه اتجاه سوريا
[موسيقى]
لكن السؤال ما الذي دفع بالمعارضه السوريه
لتغيير موقفها قبل شهر ابدت هيئه التفاوض
السوريه رفضها التام لاعاده ربط الاواصر
بين الدول العربيه وسوريا معطيات جديده
غيرت الخط البياني للمعارضه الانفتاح
العربي على دمشق كان اخرها والمشهد الختمي
كان استعاده سوريا لمقعدها في الجامعه
العربيه سبق كل هذه التطورات الحراك النشط
والزيارات المتبادله بين المسؤولين العرب
والسوريين والذي اعطى صوره واضحه للمساعي
المبذوله لاكتمال دائره الحل السياسي
متابعه لهذا الموضوع ينضم الي من دمشق قد
الحميد توفيق الكاتب الصحفي ومن لندن
الكاتب السياسي السوري فيس ساره اهلا بكما
استاذ فايز ابدا معك ما الذي غير موقف
المعارضه وابدت هذه الليونه واعتبرت بان
اليوم الموقف اصبح مناسبا لاستئناف
مفاوضات مباشره
مساء الخير الك وللساده المشاهدين وكمان
لضيفه من دمشقلب يعني انا انا فعلا شايف
انه ما في اي شيء جديد بالنسبه للمعارضه
حتى تساوي هاي الخطوه لان المعارضه في كل
الوقت سواء كان في محادثات جنيف او حتى في
محادثات استانا في اللجنه الدستوريه واي
مكان تاني لم تكن حجر عقبه في يعني في
موجهه تحديات المفاوضات سواء كانت مفاوضات
مباشره كما كان يجري في اللجنه الدستوريه
او مفاوضات غير مباشره كما جرى في اماكن
اخرى وفي جولات اخرى الحقيقه انه التحدي
الاساسي كان لقصه المفاوضات هو موقف
النظام موقف النظام اللي دائما كان عم
يعيق مو عم يعيق هو اكثر من انه حيث انه
لا يعترف اصلا بالقرار الدولي 22 54 اللي
هو الاساس التي تجري عليه كل
جولات المفاوضات
خلينا نسال استاذ عبد الحميد توفيق ارحب
بك ايضا استاذ عبد الحميد امام هذه
الليونه الى حد ما من قبل المعارضه كيف
ستتلقف دمشق هذا الموضوع هل ستقبل مثلا
بالقرارات الدوليه وحقيقه حتى الدول التي
طبعت معها مؤخرا تريد هذه
القرارات الدوليه وتريد ان تكون الامم
المتحده الضامن
مساء الخير لحضرتك ولضيفك الكريم العزيز
الاستاذ فايز ساره وللمشاهدين الكرام
اعتقد بان هذه
اسميته حضرتك الليونه كانت ربما هي ثمره
قراءه ربما موضوعيه وواقعيه لتطور الحال
الوضع السوري بصعوده الداخليه فالعربيه
فالاغلبيه الدوليه هذا من جانب من جانب
اخر من الواضح بان هذه الخطوات التي تقدمت
بها المعارضه او المواقف ايضا جاءت بعد ان
باتت الحكومه السوريه او النظام السوري او
القياده السوريه امام خيارات محدوده في ظل
التطور الحاصل في الموقف العربي تجاهه
دمشق بدءا من اعلان جده فالرباعيه عمان
الخيارات محدوده هل من الممكن ان تكون هذه
الخيارات يلقبول بالقوانين والقرارات
الامميه
اعتقد ذلك اعتقد ذلك نعم بالضبط هذا هو
الذي اقصده اما ان يكون هناك رفض واعتقد
ان المناخ العام السائد لم يعد
قابلا لان يكون هناك رفض او تشدد او عدم
او عدم استعداد
وبالتالي يكون الخيار الثاني اعذرني ولكن
دعنا نسال استاذ فايز اذا الان قبلت او
الحكومه السوريه بالقرارات الامميه يعني
ليس هناك امام المعارضه الا ان تجلس على
طاوله واحده لانه الامور منذ 12 عاما
استفز واقعيين تغيرت الان
اكيد اكيد يعني ما حدا عم يقول الامور ما
تغيرت وما حدا عم يقول انه يعني هذا الشيء
لازم يتم لكن الفكره الاساسيه انه ينبغي
ان يعلن النظام بالفعل موافقته على العلم
وبشكل واضح
مش مش تقديري انا او تقدير فلان او على
التاني هذا المفروض انه يكون في موقف رسمي
معلن بيقول انه احنا موافقين على قناتنا
اربعين على اساس انه انه يمثل للاساس في
التسويه والحل السياسي اكثر من هيك بدي
اقول انه احنا كمان شبعنا الكلام مش انا
مش انا بس سوريين والعالم كله العرب
وغيرهم شافوا كلام 12 سنه مثل ما قلت انت
عشر سنه انحكى فيهم كثير ما عاد في شيء
جديد ينحسب عبد الحميد هل تشعرون هل
تشعرون بان الحكومه اسمح لي يا استاذ فايز
لنسال استاذ عبد الحميد هل تشعرون بانه
الحكومه السوريه حقيقه هذه المره لديها
اليه جديده لديها شكل واضح للمرحله
الانتقاليه
حقيقه هل هناك المؤشرات والوقائع القول
بان الجانب السوري والحكومه السوريه باتت
اكثر استعدادا للتعاطي مع كل هذه الطروحات
وخصوصا في لبوسها الجديد الذي
تحديدا الرباعيه العربيه ولكن لابد من
النظر الى هذا الجانب بانه لا يمكن ان يتم
بين الاذن ومحاها لابد من اعاده الثقه
بهذا الامر ولا بد من خطوات عمليه كما
تفضل الاستاذ فايز يجب ان تتجاوز ثقافه
الخطابات الرنانه والعناوين يجب ان يكون
هناك
خطوات ملموسه وعمليه يمكن ان تبني الثقه
بين الطرفين ولكن اعتقد ان هذا الامر
يحتاج الى اراده من الطرفين اولا ورعايه
ايضا ودعم من الجانب العربي اولا ومن
المحيط الاقليمي الذي يرمى عبد الحميد
الدول العربيه ابدت هذا هذا الامر وخاصه
من خلال القمه ولكن استاذ فايز ايضا هناك
امر مهم بالنسبه للمعارضه الماخذ دائما
على المعارضه بانها معارضات هي مفككه الم
يحن الوقت الان ان يكون هناك معارضه موحده
بافكارها
الفكريه السياسيه
النظره للداخل السوري
فتنه يعني انا بتمنى انه انتم انتبهتوا
على البيان اللي طلع اليوم طلع امبارح
بقصه الاجتماعات المعارضه الاخيره اولا
كان كل المنصات موجوده المنصات اللي في
الهيئه
بغض النظر عن هاي الحكايه اليوم اذا كان
في اراده دوليه واراده محليه من قبل
النظام للذهاب الى حد سياسي لن يكون صعب
ابدا ابدا لن يكون صعب على
تكريس ممثل للشعب السوري للمعارضه
للجماعات السياسيه للمجتمع المدني لانه
اليوم كل العالم بيعرف انه اذا بدنا نروح
على
المشوار الاتجاه لازم يكون في ممثله
سوريين ممثل السوريين راح يكون موجود
خاصه انه هذه الممثل
يعني يعني
يتراكب من اجل للمشاركه بالمفاوضات شو
بدنا اكثر من البيان شو بدنا اكتر من من
المؤتمر الصحفي محتويات مؤتمر الصحفي رئيس
الهيئه بدر جاموس يعني شيء بالاخير عم
يقولوا وانت حضرتك حكيتي انه عم يقولوا
تعالوا نساوي مفاوضات حتى مفاوضات مباشره
اعلم انه اعزاز ممكن تكون
بس هذا الشيء كلياته ما بيكفي هذا الحكي
كنا عم نحكيه حتى قبل الثوره من ايام ربيع
دمشق عم نقول تعولا نساوي اي حل سياسي ولو
بعيد المدى
الان بحاجه بحاجه الى تنتهي هذه الازمه
سوريا بس العالم كله العالم
اكثر من عانه هو المواطن السوري حقيقه
سؤال اخير لك استاذ عبد الحميد هناك موضوع
اخر ايضا الم يحن الوقت الان بان يطلب
النظام والحكومه السوريه
توقف هذا الدعم العسكري الخارجي الروسي
الايراني خروج المليشيات كلها من سوريا
لانه هذا الامر اذا اذا حصل ايضا يعطي هذه
الاريحيه لدى المعارضه السوريه ايضا
فيما يتعلق بالجانبين الايراني والروسيا
اعتقد بانه لم الوقت لدى الجانب السوري
والحكومه السوريه لانهم لانه يعتبرهما
حليفين اما فيما يتعلق بمجمل المشهد
السوري انا اعتقد بان لا يمكن تجزئه
العقده السوريه او العقده السوريه في
مسارات ومساقات وسياقات افراديه سوريه
تعاني من وجود اكثر من اربع جيوش على
ارضها تعاني من
التقاطع وانقطاع جغرافي بين كثير من مدنها
وبلدانها والاخطر انها تعاني من الانقسام
اجتماعي جغرافي السياسي عمودي وبالتالي
هذه كلها عناوين لابد ولذلك ولذلك نسال
يعني لم يكن الوقت بان تكون سوريا بكل
فئاتها وبكل اطيافها من دون اي تدخل خارجي
عسكري يعني حتى لو كانوا حليفيها يعني مش
ضروري اذا كانوا حليفيها يكونوا متواجدين
عسكريا وخاصه بانه الامور هي الان الى حد
ما مستقره على كل حال انتهى وقتي
شكرا لك اشكرك استاذ عبد الحميد توفيق
الكاتب الصحفي ومن لندن اشكرك الكاتب
والسياسي السوري في المشاركه في اخبار
الساعه
[موسيقى]
من المتوقع مشاهدينا ان تشهد المحكمه
العليا في بريطانيا اسبوعا قضائيا حافلا
ما عوده الامير هاري الى العاصمه لتقديم
افادته يوم الاثنين ليكون بذلك اول فردا
رفيع المستوى بالاسره المالكه يقدم ادله
امام محكمه منذ عام
وسيدلي هاري بافادته في قضيه ضد مجموعه
مرر للنشر على خلفيه مزاعم حول استخدام
المجموعه لمحققين واختراقها لهاتفه للحصول
على معلومات تم استخدامها في الاخبار في
وقت تصف فيه وسائل الاعلام البريطانيه هذه
المحاكمه بقضيه العصر
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعد لحظات ريال
مدريد يعلن رحيل نجمه الفرنسي كريم بنزيما
عن الفريق وانباء عن توصل اتحاد جده الى
اتفاق للعب في صفوفه التفاصيل في مجاز
الرياضه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى اخبار الساعه صداقه
وزماله تجمع نجمه
طويله لكن المنافسه ايضا تجمعهما بامر اخر
منافسه لم تبقى في اطار الفن فحسب اذ يبدو
ان النجمين الشهيرين يتنافسان بانجاب
الاطفال في عمر متقدم فبعدما
رزقان البالغ من العمر 79 عاما بدنا في
ايترول الماضي اعلن زميله الايقون
السينمائيه ذاك فادر عن حمل شركته وهو في
عمر 83 دنيرها ان صديقه قائلا انه سعيد
بهذا الخبر خاصه
بسنوات قليله
[موسيقى]
قطعت الحكومه السنغاليه الوصول للانترنت
عبر الهاتف المحمول في ظل اعمال شغب داميه
تعرفها البلاد وقالت الحكومه السنغاليه في
بيان انها قطعت الوصول الى خدمات الانترنت
عبر الهاتف المحمول في مناطق معينه بسبب
اعمال الشغب والتي انتشرت فيها رسائل تحض
على الكراهيه
في ختام اخبار الساعه لم يبقى سوى التذكير
بابرز العناوين
في السودان انفجارات واشتباكات وعنف في
الخرطوم ودارفور المنكوبه تحصد المزيد من
الارواح
تخفض انتاجها لعام
1400 الف برميل يوميا ووزير الطاقه
السعوديه يعتبره قرارا غير مسبوق
من الهجمات الى عمليات الاسر بالجنود
الروسيه في مرمى الاستهدافات الاوكرانيه
والمناطق الحدوديه تتحول لمدن اشباح
وفي خطوه نحو انهاء الازمه السوريه هيئه
التفاوض المعارضه تعلن ان الظرف مناسب
لاستئناف المفاوضات المباشره
دائما العربيه دوت نت ومواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات